hello all and welcome to a new video on
code tech tutorials today we're going to
be talking about
programming with the open al
library this is a sound library in this
very first
tutorial we're only going to go over the
basics we're going to basically get to
playing
small sound effects so if that's all you
want for your game is to play sound
effects like jump sounds attack sounds
or whatever
this first tutorial will probably be
enough for you but
what open l can do is a lot of tuning
distance
and making reverb and all kinds of
effects and 3d sounds positional sounds
for surround sound
so that if you're in a 3d world or you
want sounds to change as they get
further away from your character
and so you can tell they're on your left
and right and all that sort of stuff
open ale can do all of that
and we will get into that in some of the
later tutorials but in this first one
we're simply going to be setting up
devices
like just making sure it actually finds
your sound devices loading up a small
sound effect and playing it back on your
speakers
and first of all i just want to show you
some of the references i used to get
started
just in case you get stuck and this
video isn't enough or whatever it may be
then matrix made a video tutorial a
while back
let's see here it's like from 2016 and
they're not bad
there's only four videos that's probably
about how many i'll do two four or five
but his are in the lightweight java game
whatever it's a job i basically have to
translate it to c plus plus code and
it's a little different
there's their main website just
openale.org which has
a whole lot of stuff and a whole lot of
info about it
there's also indie game net a complete
guide to opening
with c plus now this guide is actually
pretty good i will say
but this first guide this isn't about
playing a sound
this is about do you know template meta
programming because if you don't you're
not going to understand this code
which most new programmers don't and it
takes a while to kind of get a grasp on
that sort of thing
so i think this tutorial while it is
really good technically
the assumed knowledge is a bit high for
new coders and
i feel like tutorials should be guided
at new coders so
yeah sure you can copy paste all this
code in it'll probably work but
you're not going to understand it and
that's where things get ugly
because yeah there's this template uses
enable if which is a bit difficult to
understand especially for new coders
so i'm going to do all mining in a very
simple base of code
so yeah no template meta programming and
what i'm going to do here and that's
going to be the big difference but other
than that
actually this uh this guide here really
helped me so if you're already pretty
advanced maybe
going through this guide would be better
than my videos
i'm not sure that's up to the individual
and let's see what else is there okay
well they have a
github repo open al soft and in here of
course is all the code in the library so
you can compile and link the library
yourself
we're going to be using vc package
manager though which is basically going
to pull down this and link it
it is important to know that they do
have examples and in these examples
you will find some pretty good like bits
of code
if you're used to like opengl already
this is probably not that bad
one of the big things in here that i
used that i didn't really see elsewhere
was the in their loader they have a they
have a pretty nice
set of stuff for loading sounds and i'll
go through that when we get to the code
so this is just another good resource if
you get totally stuck or just want more
examples
you know there's a lot of options for
sounds but i'm just going to be using
some from opengameart.org because they
have some that
we're allowed to use basically and we'll
use some spell sounds
to play around a little bit here with
the code oh last but not least there is
the openal
programmers guide and this is huge it's
142 pages so
yeah you can really print out this book
if you want
but it's basically got everything about
the library it's it's a lot
there's a lot you can do with this
library here we are going to be using
microsoft visual studio and we are going
to be
linking this library with vc package
manager i have a lot of videos on
libraries on my channel
the vc package manager is probably the
quickest and easiest way to get it all
linked and ready but you can manually do
it i've done videos on how to manually
do it you can download it from github
compile and link it yourself
or you could do the vc package manager
stuff
which i'm going to do so i'm just going
to launch my command prompt
go to where i have vc package manager my
last video right before this is one on
vc package manager so if you're
completely lost on that you can follow
that or just search
search it and there's some decent
documentation on how to get started but
with windows this makes it really easy
we're just going to be sticking with
windows and some really the most
popular develop environment visual
studio so all right let me do this
okay so what you want to do is vc pkg
search open al and you'll see you get
open al soft so this is what you want to
install
you also of course want to make sure you
get the right version we're going to be
doing all 64-bit so we want to make sure
we get the 64-bit
library so we'll just do vc pkg
install openal soft
x-64 dash windows
oh i spelled install with the knee
apparently there we go
already installed so this when you do
this the first time it'll take a while
it'll compile and set everything up
another thing you want is
well let's see vcpkg search
sound file snd file we're going to be
using this to
load the data from a sound file
basically to just get that binary bit of
sound
so open ale needs to know about your
sound somehow sure you could do it
manually with c
plus plus code and actually one of those
tutorials he actually has some code in
here and how to do it manually
but it's uh this live sound file will do
it all for us so it's just going to be a
lot easier for a new
user so we want to install that too x64
windows
and i've already installed it so it will
launch visual studio we're just going to
do a new
just a new project let's do a brand new
project we're going to start it empty
and we'll just call this open it al impl
for implementation
and i will host this so
if you can't be bothered to watch a
video and the walkthrough of how
everything goes
you could just go straight to the link i
just ask that you give this video a
thumbs up before you leave if you're
going to do that
all right so we get a new solution let's
just set up some stuff
initially we said we wanted to do 64. so
let's switch this up here to 64 to make
sure it compiles with that and uses our
64-bit libraries
so we have our solution over here and
i'm going to
click show all files so i can see
everything and there's no files because
this is an empty blank project
so what we're going to do here is we're
just going to add let's see how do we
want to do this
that's that's the question so it's just
going to be a standalone app
but i'll make classes of all the stuff
we need a main so let's make a main
of course we need in maine earn zero so
let's make the classes so i'm going to
go over here add some new classes
new class and we're going to be
have one called sound device
and this one is basically going to
initialize our audio
i'm going to just hide my cam type all
this out and then i'll explain it
after the fact
[Music]
okay now that we've got a sound device
coded up
what we can do here is just go over this
real quick i made it a singleton
this doesn't have to be a single 10 but
often it makes sense for this to be a
singleton because you don't want to have
multiple instantiations of this because
this initializes our sound device if you
have multiple sound devices and want to
initialize them differently
yeah you might want to not make the
singleton because ultimately pass oh
this uh null pointer to open device it
gets whatever the default is
so you can actually query and pass in a
string of the name of the device you
want to open
if it's different than your default but
in our case we're only going to open our
default device
we might talk about switching devices
later there's some code
actually on this tutorial here about it
about getting the different ones so just
fyi
get available devices so here's some
code right here that returns a vector of
all your devices
so you can go over those and then pass
one of these device names instead of no
pointer to open that device but we're
not going to do that we're sticking with
null pointer in this particular tutorial
so next we just wanted to set up a sound
buffer let's go ahead and get to
coding up a sound buffer
[Music]
don't
[Music]
hey
[Music]
okay now we've got all this sound buffer
coded up so i will just walk through
in the header we have well this is yet
again a singleton because
we want to keep track of all our sound
buffers with this one class
to manage everything we've uploaded
uh to our memory so that way if we want
to
unload some sounds we can do that and if
we
you know we i just don't want to have
multiple classes handling it
to use this class you just need to call
the static get method
and that will initialize it which it
doesn't really need to do anything to
initialize the device that's already
initialized that's handled by this other
class
so anytime we load up a new sound effect
we're going to add it to this vector of
once we've loaded
anytime we remove a sound effect that
we're going to remove from this vector
and whenever this class gets deleted so
when we exit our program
we're going to delete all the buffers so
this delete buffers removes it from
memory
and that's going to just take care of
all of them at once
so to walk through some of these
functions okay there's the gets pretty
standard static method
so our add sound effect now this is
actually
copied from someone else because i don't
necessarily think that i can do it
better easily
so i'll just show you where i've got
that from that is actually from this
open ale
soft examples and if you go to this play
one
they have you see they use sound file
here which is what i'm using as well
and they have a load sound function i'm
using essentially the same function
which basically just grabs the sound
file from this file name and
uploads the data and then returns the
access
integer so that's where that came from
i like it a lot better than the one on
indiegamedevnet.net it's a little
simpler with that library so we got all
everything we need here just as
temporary stuff
i did have to make a few changes here
from that for this to work because there
was a few things that didn't want to
compile
here this one here this buffer is going
to be our return value and we've got
some error in
formatting just so we can make sure it
gets uploaded properly because this
checks all of that
so the first thing we do is we use that
sound file library to open it
make sure it doesn't fail make sure it
has actual frames
and we check the format here to make
sure it's a good format
then we allocate
all that memory into our member pointer
now i had to do the static cast short
because it was throwing an error it's
probably just my
compiler here it didn't like having a
void pointer assigned to this short
pointer so the static cast short was uh
one change i made that was necessary
short star rather not just short then
we just go through the rest of the stuff
we need to upload but here's where it
actually uploads we generate a buffer
that is this integer here
and then we upload our data with this
buffer data
so anytime you upload a new sound you
need to generate a buffer
and then you need to buffer the data as
you see this
takes the format the min buff of the
actual data how many bytes and the
sample rate
and then after all that's done or we can
free this member because it's already
been uploaded
and then we can close our sound file and
then it does a last check for errors
we're going to add
that buffer this buffer is just the
unsigned integer
that we need to know about to access it
to access our sound so we're going to
push that onto our vector so that we
have a list
of known buffers that are currently
uploaded and then we are going to return
our buffer so that we can actually use
it
in our program so we need to save that
somewhere
and let's see remove sound effect all
this does here is if you want to
unload a sound effect from memory
you can just pass it which buffer you
want to remove
and it goes it goes ahead and calls
delete buffer on the one if it finds it
and we're also going to erase it from
our
vector and return true if it was able to
erase it
return false if it was not able to erase
it
and also here we have a destructor that
deletes them all once i think i already
talked about
that okay so in our main to actually
load a sound this is going to return the
sound buffer
class and then this adds which then
allows us to call this add sound effect
and this add sound effect is going to
return a integer an unsigned in
so it's a uns 32t which is what the uh
al uint is it's a
32-bit unsigned integer and we'll just
call this
sound one so let's actually get a sound
here
i've got a whole bunch of sounds already
downloaded all right well we could use
any of these
these are all just og files and these
are actually
from sound starter pack from opengamer
there's a whole bunch of them you can
unpack them you can use any of them
but we just want to get the actual path
to one of these
so it'll be like so
that should handle getting the sound so
at this point we actually hit play
on our program just to make sure it
compiles we could do a
got here just to show that we went
through the code without any errors
so just uh just to make sure it actually
runs we can go ahead and do this
but the last part here is coming up and
that's actually playing the sound i will
show you how to do that here in a second
okay starting it does say it opened
on my high definition audio speakers
that's my default device and i got a
could not open
download spell and it looks like it's
because this backslash
if we're doing this backslash we need
two of them
otherwise it's it's doing something else
there we go he didn't throw an error in
loading the sound so it did actually
load the sound that time
and now the last thing we want to do is
actually
play the sound and to do that we need a
sound source
which is basically like a speaker later
on
we will have listeners as well this is a
3d sound library
so what you can do and what we will get
into later is positioning sound and when
you position sound you need to know
where the listener is but we're not
going to mess with listeners on this
tutorial
we're just going to get a source and
it's going to sound like a general sound
coming from your speakers it's not going
to be positioned
alright so let's do it let's make a
source
[Music]
friends
[Music]
okay we've got that all implemented now
all we need to do is make a sound source
we'll just call it my
speaker i guess actually that's all we
need to do
boot it of course
and we'll go my speaker dot
play and we want to play the sound one
that we loaded up
so if we run this right now the program
is going to exit immediately because
it's going to fly through all this
and this actually does it on a separate
thread natively
that's just how open ale works it'll
play the sound using its own threads
it'll it'll handle all that for you
but if you exit your program right after
you play you're not really going to hear
the sound you're just going to return 0
right away so usually have this in a
loop you know with your game or whatever
running so you actually hear your sound
but in our case here
i'm going to have to put in a little
hack so in my sound source
let me walk through this code and i'll
get to the get to the hack it's this
code i commented out
that is sort of the uh the okay so
pretty standard class here when we play
it all we need
is the uh which buffer to play
so it needs to know how to access it or
which one access in the memory of
uploaded stuff this has to be one that's
been uploaded
now we're holding some private variables
and these are just like
like your your speaker variables
basically
for the sound i guess some of it would
be like a mixer board type thing
because you have a pitch we're just
leaving it the fault of one pitch so
it's not like slowed down or sped up
and we have a gain which is basically
your volume
volume one is the default it'll play as
it is and we have positions
we're just setting these all to zero
right now this is basically the location
of your speaker we'll mess with that in
later tutorials velocity here
velocity is uh for moving sounds
basically uh we'll get into that more
later but we're not going to have it
moving so it's just zero so you can
basically have it like going in a
direction for maybe a car whizzing by
and whether we want to loop the sound or
not we're going to keep this fall so we
just want to play it once
and this source is stored variable
basically this speaker is also uploaded
into memory and the only thing we have
to access it
is this you integer in this buffer here
is basically what we've last played if
it's zero hasn't played anything
so now let's go over to the
implementation to take a look when we
set up
this class for the first time we're
going to populate this source so anytime
you instantiate a new
sound source like we did right here it
goes ahead and it sets up a speaker
because of this constructor so gens the
source
and it sets the pitch gain and
everything to our defaults
let's see when we destroy this class we
want to delete our source
which is basically our speaker here we
want to delete that
off the audio memory and let's see this
play
function is is the big one it's the main
thing
so when any time we hit play on the
speaker
we're going to tell it which buffer to
play now as a bit of an optimization i
like to
see if it's changed then we're going to
set it to whatever you told it to play
and then we're gonna
upload that as the buffer if it already
is what you told it to play
then we don't have to upload this data
and just play the source
so let's go ahead and give it a go
about float property a little error
there we'll fix that in a second
okay so all that error was was uh we
were buffering an integer as a flow
that's this would be source i so what we
want to do to make sure the sound
actually plays is uh we just want to
block the thread since we're not in like
a
loop where the program is going to
continue
yeah we're just going to do this little
while loop while it's playing so we have
a state
and this sets the state as it goes and
eventually it'll set to not playing i
believe it
and once it's anything but this plane
it'll actually exit the program relaxes
so now we should hear our sound if
everything is going good
yep there we go that was our sound so we
could
that's just a plain old spell we could
load up any little sound effect here
anything you want
and you could add multiple like i don't
know we could just do like
sound two we could pick another spell
here whatever this
is magic fail
sound two
and then we could do sound two and they
should play one after the other
yeah we could do it on the same speaker
it's actually fine
we could also make separate speakers for
these two
there we go well let me know if you have
any questions about this first episode i
will upload the code
link down below if you have any
suggestions you're welcome to leave a
comment but also you're more welcome to
just
edit the code and make a pool request so
if there's something that is like
terribly terribly wrong in this code
that you see because i'm not perfect
i love c plus plus but as with any c
plus plus coder
and any coder in general our code's
never perfect you know if you see
something you can fix
cool fix it and as we go along hopefully
this code can stay maintained
well and look forward to episode two or
i'm gonna get into the next part of this
i'm not sure if i'm gonna do streaming
or listening
because those are those are kind of two
big subjects but
i'll try to cover just one subject
onward from this i know this one's
pretty long it's probably gonna be the
longest one
at least that's my intention also i do
have a patreon
if you want to be involved further in
the community you're welcome to join
that we have a private
discord so if you want to talk to me
every day i do check that discord daily
also i'm going to
put up some some threads on patreon
about
what the community would like me to
focus on next
so right now i'm basically just doing
whatever i feel like
as i get uh some supporters over there
on patreon
and put some uh some voting up about
what to focus on
i can actually have some guidance on
where
the most supportive of my community
would like me to focus and whether it be
libraries video editing or whatnot
i will oblige uh based on how that goes
thank you all for watching thank you for
any and all of the support hope your
coding goes well
i'll see you guys in the next episode
matt from codetechnatorials
over and out peace guys